dans la station des deux âges il y à la
neige les skieurs et les casse cou mais
depuis peu en bas des pistes il y à une
nouveauté cet étrange bulles blanches
pour l'après-ski une attraction d'un
nouveau genre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour on voudrait essayer le
simulateur d'avant
leur ticket en poche ils vont monter
dans cet étrange appareil surnommé le
robot coster un simulateur d'avalanche
c'est page armand
une fois enfermés dans la capsule le
robot de 7 mètres de haut et une vidéo
en trois dimensions vous met dans la
peau d'un skieur qui sort des sentiers
battus
mauvaise surprise
une immense coulée de neige se déclenche
derrière vous
ouais
c'est alors que le robot articulé bouge
dans tous les sens pour leur faire subir
la terreur d'une avalanche
sur le terrain sous la neige ils sont
emprisonnés sous la neige leur durée de
vie est estimée à 15 minutes
cet appareil de foire permet de
sensibiliser les skieurs aux risques
encourus en cas de hors piste
c'est quoi
cette simulation c'est pas mal on se
rend compte que si on est pris de temps
je peux rien faire
attendre le chien de la famille
c'est vraiment
c'est marrant tant que cela reste une
simulation
car la saison dernière quarante et une
personnes sont mortes dans des
avalanches en france au mauvais endroit
au mauvais moment
la majeure partie des accidents sont dus
à la pratique du hors-piste
des statistiques alarmantes pour les
stations de ski
aujourd'hui les professionnels de la
haute montagne doivent faire face à un
dilemme
attirer les touristes toujours plus
nombreux en quête de sensations fortes
mais en même temps dissuader les
téméraires de prendre des risques
mais pour l'instant ce que met surtout
en avant les publicités ce sont des fans
de poudreuse qui dévale dépendent de
neige vierge dans des espaces sauvages
en moins d'une demi heure le skieur
venus des villes se retrouvent au coeur
de la haute montagne et de ses dangers
zones à risque menaces d'avalanches
tout une signalétique que beaucoup ne
respectent pas
le problème c'est que neuf joueurs sur
dix n'ont pas assez d'expérience pour
pratiquer leurs pistes
et en cas d'accident en dehors des zones
balisées il sera parfois très difficile
d'aller leur sauver la vie
[Musique]
la mecque du ski alpin se trouve à
chamonix est précisément en eau de
l'aiguillé du midi un sommet mythique
pour s'y rendre il faut prendre un
téléphérique puis un ascenseur qui monte
dans la roche à plus de 3800 mètres
d'altitude la salanque où
se mêlent emilie 3842
le hors-piste certains en ont fait leur
métier comme aurélien ducroz à 28 ans il
est champion du monde de freeride une
discipline récente qui consiste à skis
et dépendent raid en terrain vierge au
bureau
coûterait l'ailé du midi d'ossau m en
1842 m et
là pas de mots pour décrire ce qui se
passe ici
un endroit magique mais très dangereux
en cas d'avalanche aurélien a sur lui
tout un attirail pour réagir en cas de
problème
une sonde un bâton télescopique pour
retrouver un corps sous la neige et la
pelle
l'appel et son manche la rva toujours le
jour qu'en mettre en route vers la rva
un appareil qui permet de localiser la
personne qui le porte
de votre billet aurélien a même emmené
avec lui un baudrier pour se sortir
d'affaires s'ils étaient entraînés dans
une crevasse coup
tu vas voir on va descendre l'art est tu
voir cette médiane dans l'ambiance
le départ annonce la couleur une
descente en cordée sur une crête qui
surplombe un précipice de plus de 2000
mètres
ils ont bien arrosé l'ain
bien l'enfer
bien planter
15 minutes de descente à haut risque et
le hors piste peut commencer
un itinéraire non sécurisés pat damage
pas d'entretien pas de pancartes
c'est ici qu'aurélien s'entraîne dans la
vallée blanche un itinéraire de 20 km
qui descend au milieu de glaciers géant
dans ce cadre majestueux les pièges sont
nombreux
pande vertigineuse crevasses et
aujourd'hui aurélien vient de passer à
côté d'un gros danger
une avalanche de séracs des blocs de
glace qui chutent de manière
imprévisible
et roulait forcément il s'effondre de
temps quoi fur et à mesure
autrement dit malgré leur minutieuse
préparation ces professionnels du
freeride ne peuvent pas toujours évité
le pire
quelques jours plus tard les meilleurs
spécialistes de la discipline dont
aurélien se retrouvent pour une étape
des championnats du monde en face du
mont blanc
[Musique]
on est au départ
au départ numéro un
lors d'une compétition en 2007 l'un des
participants a trouvé la mort c'est free
riders n'ont pas le droit à l'erreur sur
leur appareil photo il regarde les
clichés de la zone de descente pour
identifier les passages à risque
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de menace
avérée d'avalanche
aurélien enchaînent les figures sans
grande difficulté apparente
[Musique]
mais le risque zéro n'existe pas
son collègue xavier de le rue se lance
dans une pente vertigineuse
et à chaque virage il provoque des
coulées de neige
qui si les conditions météo étaient
différentes pourraient se transformer en
dangereuse avalanche
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui est arrivé à ce
surfeur expérimenté il y a maintenant
trois ans
xavier est un miraculé lors d'une
descente en hors piste pour le tournage
d'une vidéo de démonstration il a eu la
peur de sa vie aujourd'hui il en sourit
mais xavier a frôlé la mort
c'était
balalas a décrit bien le truc c'était
une super session là c'était journée de
fin de saison là où il ya plus de marsac
incroyable du soleil de la neige fraîche
les conditions rêvées pour le freeride
seulement après son premier virage
c'est le cauchemar
j'ai fait partir un petit plat
voilà j'ai réussi à m'échapper c'est
toujours garder suffisamment de vitesse
avec des plantes sortie est en fait
cette plaque a mis tellement de pression
sur tout le reste du manteau neigeux que
tout d'un coup j'ai montagne qui s'est
enfin voilà qui s'est effritée autour de
moi et donc voilà je me suis retrouvé
dans une énorme machine à laver je suis
tombé inconscient hyper vite donc en
nombre je n'ai pas vu grand chose et
puis je me suis réveillé j'étais en
train de faire transférer à l'hôpital
donc je pensais pas que je me ferais
tiré sur autant le mans après une fois
que l'accident est arrivé puis qu'on
réalise
voilà ce que enfin qu'une fois que j'ai
réalisé ce que ce que j'avais vécu
si ben là
je peux remercier quelqu'un
l'erreur de xavier c'est d'être parti
trop tard dans la journée la neige
s'étaient réchauffées en surface ce qui
a rendu instable le manteau neigeux
ces avalanches de plaques sont souvent
déclenchées par les skieurs eux-mêmes
et neuf fois sur dix les équipes de
secours arrivent trop tard
l'année dernière dans les alpes un
peloton de gendarmerie par en
intervention sur une avalanche
le médecin film lui-même la mission
l'équipe de secours a peu d'espoir de
retrouver vivante la personne disparue
un homme d'une cinquantaine d'années qui
faisait seul lieu hors piste
car la catastrophe a eu lieu 45 minutes
plus tôt et la durée de vie moyenne
d'une victime ensevelie sous la neige et
d'un quart d'heure
équipé de son appareil de localisation
le médecin cherche l'endroit où pourrait
être le ski à part en bas
l'homme est retrouvé sous un mètre de
poudreuse
surprise il est encore en vie
sa jambe tremble
il est en hypothermie au bord du coma
s'il n'est pas décédé au bout de
quelques minutes
c'est que par chance la neige au dessus
de lui était assez légère pour le
laisser respirer
l'homme est transporté d'urgence à
l'hôpital il s'en sortira
miraculeusement sans séquelles
comment éviter de se retrouver sous une
avalanche et comment se comporter si
cela arrive aujourd'hui les stations
organise des stages de formation pour
les adeptes de hors piste et de
sensations fortes
comme thomas un collégien venue de lyon
ils sont une dizaine à suivre leurs
moniteurs pour un cours très particulier
est ce que vous connaissez les trois
types d'avalanche qui existe
après il ya les vins de printemps
la pire tour tout le monde tous les
skieurs s'élancent
à sport
comme la wii la wii un lay up une petite
la plaque à vent c'est une accumulation
de neige donc qui est formée par le vent
en grande partie qui peut se détacher
tout seul parce qu'elle va glisser sur
la neige d'en dessous ou alors c'est ça
le pire c'est quand un tueur va arriver
qui met un coup de poids de sur la neige
ça va casser et ça va faire partir une
claque et ça c'est super retraite savoir
interpréter la montagne et ses dangers
pour ces ados c'est essentiel car ils
sont tous passionnés par le hors piste
même si pour thomas et ses copains au
moment de s'élancer ce n'est pas
toujours évident
c'est un peu comme wes en torrent
bon normalement on va savourer j'espère
mais que ferons thomas et ses amis si un
jour ils se retrouvent ensevelies sous
une avalanche
après la théorie place aux conseils de
survie
qu'est ce que vous mettez vous dans
votre sac à dos d'habitude pas de sac à
dos
à manger à boire
sont quand même bravo ok donc sa pelle
sonde c'est obligatoire je suis qui va
racheter sans ça
tant pis pour lui
safty gags passer un petit truc à
connaître tu prends un peu de lipstick
et tu prends ne serait-ce qu'un bout de
tissu d'un habitudes d'un bout de papier
a un goût de pq et ben ça va brûler
super bien tu peux faire une torche peut
le manger aussi s'il faut vraiment
on parle de survivre
mais le meilleur moyen de survivre à une
avalanche le sac à dos airbags un tout
nouvel équipement
il suffit aux skieurs de tirer sur la
manette
pour qu'une bouée de sauvetage se gonfle
lui permettant de flotter au dessus de
la coulée de neige
on leur apprend aussi à se servir de la
rva pour localiser et dégager d'autres
skieurs qui seraient pris sous la neige
c'est rapproche comme un avion qui pose
plus l'intensité du bip est forte plus
la victime est proche
donc là tu as trouvé la victime
c'est bon pour lui il a mis beaucoup
la jeune génération apprend les gestes
qui sauvent
seulement beaucoup de free riders
continue à faire du hors piste sans
équipement cette saison déjà quatorze
personnes sont mortes dans des
avalanches